[Applause]
[Music]
okay guys this week is super
action-packed
we've got hedgehogs we've got dudes in
cool suits we've got megalomaniacal
villains and it's all happening on the
same day hit that subscribe button and
you'll get new releases like these
delivered to you every Sunday now here
we go with some of the hottest of those
action-packed games coming this week if
you're one of those Sonic fans who fell
off when the blue hedgehog went 3d I
don't blame you but Sonic mania looks a
lot like the classic 16-bit games you
remember including using Sonic and Tails
together or letting a second player take
control of the flying fox and of course
Knuckles the Echidna
is also playable no matter who you
choose you'll be zipping around both new
levels and remix versions of classic
stages like Green Hill Zone expect
plenty of bonus stages and Eggman fights
- it's all waiting for you on ps4 Xbox
one PC and Nintendo switch on Tuesday
August 15th and if you want to get
caught up on any of the Hedgehog's
adventures you missed you can always
check out our hefty history of Sonic
video maybe you prefer shooting instead
of running in that case let me introduce
you to mater fall this side-scrolling
shooter is from the makers of resogun
and next machina but rather than play as
a spaceship or robot you're just a dude
in a fancy futuristic suit Darrow can
jump and run around while blasting
aliens or use his suit to generate
protective shields and create new
platforms matter fall has some great
style and it's coming exclusively to ps4
on the 15-man this really is a
fast-paced week because we're also
getting agents of mayhem the latest game
from Saints Row developer volition the
titular agents of mayhem work for an
organization dedicated to stopping a
legion of supervillains what that means
for you is an open-world game with a
dozen radically different heroes
fighting in a futuristic version of
Seoul South Korea
you've got the Colombian sky pirate
fortune navy chief hardtack and movie
star Hollywood
just to name a few you can try them for
yourself on ps4 Xbox one and PC on the
15th just be prepared for some major
not-safe-for-work action and humor
especially from Hollywood ostentatious
showboat Oh reality TV stuff and let's
take a breather from all this action
with observer or not since this is a
cyberpunk horror game a digital plague
has overtaken Poland in the year twenty
eighty four and detective Daniel Lazar
scheme has a job to do that job involves
using Dream Eater technology to hack
into the minds of suspects looking for
both electronic and biological evidence
it sounds pretty trippy and you can
investigate for yourself on ps4 Xbox one
and PC on the 15th time to speed things
up again with nidhogg - if you play the
minimalistic first game you'll be
familiar with the goal kill your
opponent and cross to the other side of
the screen until you reach the end of
the map this time you'll be doing it
with a grotesque new art style a bunch
of new weapons and full character
customisation don't forget all the new
maps either need a hug two slashes and
leaps onto ps4 and PC on the 15th and
those are the hottest games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with more games next week